au jour tout le monde je sais pas à quoi
je ressemble mais j'espère
là je m'appelle à masaya je suis
sénégalaise et jeu
vraiment contente d'être parmi vous
aujourd'hui alors je vais aller direct
au but je sais pas pour vous mais moi
depuis que je suis petit j'ai toujours
voulu comprendre le monde autour de moi
et donc j'étais ce genre de petit que
vous avez dû voir
on disait niel pour autant de questions
qui posent trop de questions on fait
juste
tout ce qu'ont expliqué c'était pourquoi
mais pourquoi et pourquoi
à tel point que le système m'a rappelé à
certains moments de façon ferme tu te
tais tu es une femme et une fille en ces
temps là et il faut savoir être
invisible et faire ce qui va plaire à la
société au début j'ai résisté et la
société vous rappelle très vite votre
place
parce qu'elle est quand même assez bien
structuré organisé et donc à un certain
moment j'ai accepté ce que cette société
me disais et je me suis renfermé sur
moi-même et d'une certaine manière je
dirais même que j'ai disparu
j'ai complètement disparu parce que je
n'arrivais pas à trouver mon chemin
et vu que j'avais toujours ce besoin de
connecter avec les autres de connecter
avec quelque chose autour de moi de
sentir les choses je me suis réfugié
dans la nature dans les éléments les
animaux les plantes
parce qu'au moins eux ils me disaient
pas de me taire au moins avec eux je
vous pouvez échanger j'avais le
sentiment de sentir des choses des
vibrations des énergies d'être acceptée
et dans cette expérience de la nature
j'ai eu à prendre beaucoup de leçons et
je me suis rendu compte que la nature
est un grand maître
oui on peut beaucoup apprendre avec les
gens avec la société mais à la la je
vous invite vraiment à passer plus de
temps et de vous exposer à la nature et
de voir ce qu'elle a à vous offrir
un des éléments dont je veux parler
aujourd'hui et que je vais faire une
connexion avec les dés de chez vous avez
trouvé très bizarre au début c'est long
un élément ça avance trop vite là où via
ça ne marche pas l'eau c'est tellement
qui nous enseigne beaucoup de leçons
d'être fluide des tragédies de s'adapter
de ne jamais être contenue d'inclure de
données de respecter et aussi de
connecter avec l'autre et le plus j'ai
pris du temps à observer cette eau qui
est tellement essentiel à toute la
création
à nous tous dont on dépend j'ai eu avoir
des connexions incroyable pour nous en
tant que leader alors ça commence par
une histoire d'amour si il n'y avait pas
d'amour entre deux êtres mme d'hydrogène
et un atome d'oxygène
s'il n'y avait pas de désir de
coopération de désir d'union entre ses
actuels là il n'y aurait pas d'eau et
donc
tout ce que vous regardez autour de vous
sous forme physique dans la nature et le
résultat d'atomes ou de molécules qui
ont désiré qui désirent se rassembler
coopérer créer tous aux clients qui est
devant nous sous forme physique et qui
est beau c'est quand même incroyable
et en regardant du point de vue
scientifique
on voit que la liaison entre et des
atomes d'hydrogène et la raison derrière
l'union entre différentes molécules
d'eau et l'eau est derrière cette map
derrière cette cette connexion des mots
de livres aux molécules d'eau deux
propriétés essentielles de l'eau qui est
important de retenir quand on pense au
lieu de chimie une la capacité de
cohésion dans la cohésion
il s'agit de molécules d'eau qui se
collent facilement l'une à l'autre et
qui s'attire naturellement donc une
goutte d'eau va attirer une autre goutte
d'eau et vous pouvez voir ça quand vous
observez des feuilles d'arbres et qui à
la pluie des gouttes d'eau dessus ou
bien des cirfa de surface si heureuse et
dont l'adhérence le phénomène de la
durance donc une adhésion
les molécules d'eau au une facilité
encore plus grande que dans la cohésion
de se coller à des molécules d'autre
nature
d'autres éléments et vous voyez ça
lorsque vous avez de l'eau dans un verre
l'eau arrive à glisser dans le vert à se
positionner le vert nous arrivons à être
humain a fonctionné à vivre parce que
notre sang circule dans notre corps donc
ce liquide se sent à la base avec de
l'eau arrive a circulé dans leur corps
l'eau est constamment en connexion avec
des mots
que d'autres natures la peau les visites
en guerre ou même des fois la terre où
elle pénètre la terre rentrer au niveau
des racines d'un arbre
le tronc d'un arbre jusqu'au branches et
les feuilles ce extraordinaire parce que
cette eau est capable d'atteindre et de
faire tellement de choses incroyables
parce qu'au départ il ya une histoire
d'amour entre deux éléments un désir de
fusion de deux verlan et ce désir de
fusion ne s'est pas arrêté à ce départ
là il continue dans la cohésion
là vous avez une goutte d'eau une autre
goutte d'eau va attirer l'autre goutte
d'eau et c'est comme ça que sabine mass
domi et vous avez des rivières et des
essayant et la fusion ne s'arrête pas là
quand elle rentre en contact avec
d'autres éléments différents lots au
lieu de préférer rester en boule avec
elle-même ou entre l eau
elle décide de se pendre pensez-y
quand on parle de l'île chine pensez-y
quand vous voulez vous avoir un impact
dans la vie des gens pensez-y qu'on
voulait transformer vos vies ou vos
sociétés ou vos communautés
comment arriver à faire cela si vous
n'arrivez pas à voir un esprit une
pratique de vie qui est dans la cohésion
et l'adhésion est au fond de cela
l'amour
beaucoup de gens ne savent pas ou ne
réalise pas nous ne sont pas au courant
que l'eau a une mémoire une forme de
conscience et c'est ce que nous rappelle
le travail d'un docteur japonais massot
et motos qui dans les années 90 a voulu
faire une étude pour confirmer ces idées
là et donc il a pris des deux lots de
différents endroits les a cristallisé
avant de les cristalliser les a exposés
à différentes conditions
des fois des sons des fois des mots des
paroles une intention a été rappelé les
a cristallisé les a aidés à congeler
et après à étudier les cristaux à niveau
nucléaire pouvoir
est ce qu'il y avait un effet alors je
vous laisse juger par vous même
voilà le cristal 1 et cristaux du
barrage de fujisawa si vous connaissez
comprenez comme un barrage fonctionne
l'eau est bloquée et l'eau est stagnante
et hinault qui ne circulent pas n'a pas
de vie et se polluer se détériore donc
il a commencé par cet élément pour voir
comment se passer l'eau de fujisawa
après il a pris la même eau il l'a
confiée à un prêtre il lui a demandé de
faire une cuillère sur l'eau après la
prière voici à quoi ressemble le cristal
de l'eau phénoménal et il a continué
cette expérience en exposons différents
types d'eau à du son ici la symphonie de
mozart ont parlé de mozart tout à
l'heure une chanson de john lennon
imagine que beaucoup d'entre nous
connaissent le mot atx est belle ou
thiébaut la paix
la sagesse c'est incroyable non merci
regardez à quoi ressemble le cristal de
merci parce que l'eau a été exposé à ce
mot là et ça continue je vais te tuer
regardez à quoi ressemble cristal
qu'est ce tu puisses voilà à quoi
ressemble le cristal par contre le mot
amour on n'a même pas dit je t'aime on a
juste d amour
cette découverte nous montre que les
molécules d'eau peuvent avoir une
réaction ont une réaction à leur
environnement à ce à quoi ils sont
exposés
et ça c'est très important aux graves
même je devrais dire quand on pense que
plus de 70% de la planète des rideaux
sais pas si vous réalisez cette planète
d'accueil nous trouvent en ce moment il
ya 70% que de l'eau mais ce qui est
encore plus phénoménal
pour moi ce que je suis humain c'est que
l'homme le corps de l'homme plus de 70%
de l'homme est fait à base d'eau aussi
nous sommes issus essentiellement de
locaux alors il ya matière à se poser la
question de l'impact de nos pensées de
nos intentions d environnement auquel
nous nous exposons sur notre être sur
notre devenir
sur notre capacité à exister à avoir un
impact l'impact escompté qu'on
souhaiterait avoir dans nos sociétés
dans la communauté dans nos familles ou
simplement être un leader
le monde que nous avons hérité en ce
moment on se tait en cette ère du 21e
siècle est chargé de challenges énumérés
dans toutes ces bulles là que ce soit
les conflits sociaux urbanisation
changements climatiques la santé et
cetera et cetera
le chantier est énorme il ya de quoi
être découragé surtout qu'on a parlé de
crier crise de l'éducation crise
existentielle
etc etc mais il n'ya pas se décourager
pour moi et c'est ce que l'histoire de
ma vie m'a rappelé d'autres personnes
que j'ai eu la bénédiction de rencontrer
mon rappelait aussi l'importance de ceux
qui résident en nous de ce que nous
sommes c'est d'excellence cette
ingéniosité cette puissance incroyable
qui en nous et un de ses reflets un de
ses mémoires miroir en nous ces lots
look à une puissance incroyable qui nous
rappelle notre capacité en ou d'être de
s'adapter d'être malléable d'être
flexible de changer je me tiens devant
vous parce que j'ai eu à changer et
changer changer tellement de fois et je
n'aurais pas accompli des choses que
j'aurais eu à accomplir dans ma vie
aujourd'hui être là si ce n'était pas
pour ses capacités à être flexible et
que la nature m'a enseigné que
l'aumônier parce que j'ai pris le temps
d'observer autour de moi et de me
laisser inspirer parce que je n'arrivais
pas trouvé en ce temps là les
inspirations autour de moi
or je suis sénégalaise et donc je vais
commencer par le sénégal cette carte ne
rend même pas justice à toutes les
autres opportunités que ce pays nous
offre mais j'ai une vision et c'est pour
ça que j'ai quitté mon travail à près
d'un an une bonne situation à l'étranger
après près de 18 ans à l'étranger pour
venir travailler pour mon continent
travaille pour mon peuple
mais surtout être moi même parce que si
je sais pas pour vous mais moi depuis
que je suis petit j'ai toujours aimé
m'amuser j'ai toujours voulu être moi
même et c'est quelque chose qui est
tellement important pour moi qu'après
plusieurs années à l'étranger
j'appellerai sas des années d'exil il
était temps pour moi de m'assumer et de
rentrer et d'être moi est ce que j'offre
aujourd'hui à beaucoup de gens que
j'accompagne dans le développement
personnel dans le coaching
je ne vais pas étudié à l'école je
faisais partie de ceux qui détestent et
l'école et qui détestent entendant
l'école et à tel point que j'ai pris le
temps d'étudier le problème est d'avoir
des idées des solutions que je développe
petit à petit pour changer les choses et
si on regarde le sénégal et qu'on voit
les capacités que l'on nous rappelle ses
propriétés de cohésion et d'adhésion
imaginez un peuple sénégalais on
commence par le sénégal si on pouvait se
regarder dans la glace
s'il vous plaît mes frères et soeurs
sénégalais et sénégalaises
si on pouvait vraiment se regarder dans
la glace et voir comment nous sommes
vraiment comment nous fonctionnons
comment nous avons été conditionnés
socialiser à être est ce que c'est un
fonctionnement qui permet une émergence
est ce que c'est un fonctionnement qui
permet l'épanouissement de ces gens
de la libération
la libéralisation de leur créativité de
leur génie ou est ce que c'est un
fonctionnement qui est plutôt basé sur
la division et la peur la méfiance comme
l'un de nos speaker le disais tout à
l'heure où on a du mal à travailler les
uns et les autres et on vit dans le
secret et on pense que l'autre venu lui
de l'autre est jaloux et l'audois même
aller voir des forces occultes pour nous
barrer le chemin
je ne sais pas pour vous mais on a beau
investir dans les écoles classiques
on a beau investir dans la santé on a
beau investir et l'investir recevoir des
aides de multinationales des ong de
grandes organisations internationales
tant que l'africain et l'afrique
chacun de nous n'aura pas pris sa part
de responsabilité est pris à développer
une prise de conscience de réaliser sa
contribution à la situation actuelle
les choses n'ont pas changé parce que
l'investissement majeur qui doit avoir
lieu
c'est une révolution au niveau
individuel pour après être collective
c'est un réveil des consciences
un réveil des esprits
vous savez vous en à une humanité on dit
humanité on pense à un groupe
ce symbole est tellement fort que chacun
de nous est un humain et dans cette
humanité en chacun de nous vous avez une
dualité extraordinaire est ce que vous
prenez le temps d'observer
regardez vos corps deux yeux deux
oreilles de narines d'élèves de bras de
tout et en dualité les textes sacrés
nous rappelle que seul dieu pour ceux
qui croient en dieu bien sûr seul dieu
est unique et que tout est créé en
dualité minimum alors si vous essayez de
courir
si vous essayez d'arriver à une
destination le plus rapidement possible
si vous essayez d'avancé dites moi
comment vous allez y arriver si vous
êtes amputé d'un pied ou bien un de vos
pieds fut mal et ne fonctionne pas allez
vous être aussi rapide que la personne
qui a deux pieds qui fonctionnait la
même manière l'humanité est fait d'un
homme et d'une femme sans la femme il
n'y a pas d'humanité sans l'en il n'y a
pas d'humanité
alors à quel jeu joue en ou en essayant
de contrôler et de d'amputer de bloquer
une partie de cette humanité en pensant
que l'autre jambe va pouvoir avancer que
si tu m'as ni té va être en bonne santé
quand je pense à l'afrique du 21e siècle
quand je pense au sénégal de la 21ème
siècle et les différents pays africains
du 21e siècle
je vois des gens qui réalisent
l'importance de la cohésion et de
l'adhésion de savoir travailler ensemble
de savoirs resserré et créer des liens
de savoir être en accord synchronisée on
parle de leadership
il n'y a pas de leadership si vous ne
savez pas fusionner
rien n'est de votre contrôle rien ou de
votre ca le plus vous vous à vous
avancez le plus vu réaliser que nous
contrôler rien les expériences de la vie
nous le rappellent tous les jours et
aller plus grande échelle
l'afrique oulala une des raisons mais
aussi vos karaka j'ai quitté tout et je
suis rentré ce que j'ai toujours été
amoureuse de l'afrique ce continent noir
cette belle peau noire ses beaux cheveux
crépus fille j'ai toujours été une fan
de cette afrique
jusqu aux dreadlocks et vous vous rendez
compte qu'on a cinq ans plus de 50 pays
dans ce continent et on ne réalise pas
comment ce continent regorge oui on nous
dit que ce continent est pauvre on nous
dit on nous dit tellement de choses mais
nous qui sommes africains qu est ce qu
on sait que savons nous de notre afrique
que savons nous de notre héritage
ancestral
que savons nous de notre terre
connaissons nous mêmes les différentes
aires de l'afrique de nos propres pays
est ce qu'on connaît les deux derniers
rivier les différentes rivières les
différents arbres de nos pays
est ce qu'on connaît les animaux de nos
pays
comment voulez vous développez vos pays
comment voulons nous développer nos
nations si nous n'avons pas d'amour pour
notre terre oui au nom de la
globalisation c'est beaucoup de choses
sur l'étranger mais savons-nous quelques
et l'afrique
savons nous ce que l'afrique a contribué
à la civilisation du monde entier je
vous défie pour ceux qui n'ont pas
encore commencé ce cheminement de lire
des illustres personnes comme cheikh
anta diop et d'autres nous pas seulement
africains et de la diaspora quelques
scans à l'étranger de vous ressourcer
parce que si nos ancêtres étaient
aujourd'hui ici parmi nos il serait
dépassé
quand on sait la contribution de
l'africain
dans ce monde l'afrique a toujours été
leur jeu dans tous les sens à tel point
je sais pas si vous êtes beaucoup dans
certains d'entre vous ont dû voir cette
carte géographique de ce cartographe
allemand kai croiser qui a voulu
vraiment choqué les mentalités et permet
aux gens de réaliser certaines réalités
on parle de l'école les cartes
géographiques on utilise dans les écoles
ne sont pas corrects et beaucoup n'ont
jamais vraiment réaliser la vraie taille
de l'afrique alors c'est tellement
appris à échelle réelle les tailles des
plus grandes puissances économiques du
monde
on parle des états unis on parle de la
chine
on parle de toute l'europe de l'ouest du
portugal à la france à l'angleterre à la
belgique à l'espagne etc
les pays de l'europe de l'est
l'australie le japon de l'inde
il les a superposé sur la carte réelle
de l'afrique en taille réelle il ya
encore de l'espace vous vous rendez
compte
vous vous rendez compte du continent qui
nous nourrit qui nous a couvé et
continue de nous rendre honneur comme on
le fait comme il le fait et ça m'a
interpellé
parce que quand vous comprenez comment
les économies les différends politiques
internationales fonctionne vous et je
sois son histoire vous savez que ces
forces économiques ces puissances
économiques dépendent de l'afrique pour
être et continuer d'exister au moment où
je vous parle des études montrent que 20
à londres
rien que londres des entreprises cotées
de la bourse de londres détiennent
possède ça leur appartient plus de 100
trillions de dollars de ressources
africaines
je vous parle de mille billions et on
parle de pauvreté
où sont les africains
est ce que vous savez que 67 % des
terres arables de la planète se trouvent
en afrique c'est pas par hasard que
toutes les multinationales en semences
font la course en ce moment dans les
pays africains achètent des terres
cultivées exporte des rapports comme le
mackenzie paul ii les lions en mouvement
numéro 2 qui est sorti en 2016 nous
rappelle que d'ici d'ici 2040 les terres
africaines vont être les scènes les
solitaires qui vont nourrir toute la
planète et on parle de fin on parle de
famine on parle de sous développement
on parle d'émergence on y sérieux là
qu'est ce qu'on attend
qu'est ce qui se passe avec nous on
hypnotisé en somme on somnole on est
drogué c'est quoi le problème
d'après vous qu'est ce qui fait qu'on
est aussi passif comme peuple est-ce que
vous avez idée des ressources que ce
continent à près de 70% des ressources
minérales de la planète se trouvent en
afrique
vous le saviez
que se passe-t-il que se passe-t-il je
me pose la question
le paradoxe de l'abondance alors voilà
une raison peu à que je suis rentré
parce que je pouvais plus continuer de
rester regarder que nos gens ne font
rien oui le système éducatif est en
crise il a échoué
mais le plus gros échec c'est lorsque
l'humain lui même à oublier qui il est
et je suis du coup tout coeur avec tous
ses esprits tout ces intelligences qui
nous ont précédés qui sont là et qui
vont et viennent dans le futur pour
aider à reconstruire notre psychisme qui
a été violée il y à bien longtemps ou
aujourd'hui notre génération n'a aucune
conscience de qui et les ce qu'elle a et
ce qu'elle peut faire alors je vous dis
et je vous rappelle
vous êtes au tout autour de vous et au
essentiellement vous est malléable
vous êtes adaptable vous pouvez vous
changez vous pouvez vous transformez il
n'y a rien qui puisse vous bloquez et
l'eau est un élément tellement
extraordinaire il fait son chemin
et continue à faire son chemin qu'ils
fassent face à quelques obstacles un
rocher un mur il va contourner l'eau
avec beaucoup de douceur des fois où
avec force mais il ferait son chemin
l'eau atteindra feu l'eau peut éroder
une pierre lot de briser un rocher lots
nourrit la vie donne la vie rassemble et
une source de joie
soyez ça réveillons nous voilà mon
regard sur une nouvelle afrique
merci
[Applaudissements]